exhibit is called jelly to the
experience have lots of Interactive's in
it and also 15 different species of
jellies and the jellies experience some
of them our visitors will have seen
before but also some new surprising
jellies we haven't displayed before so a
lot of the jellyfish in the new exhibit
are going to be tropical jellyfish
species coming from all around the world
that's really about how they move and
what they just the experience of
watching them so this exhibit capitalize
on that but luckily get that to be more
interactive for the user and gets broken
down into different sections like draw
gel the experience you get the whole
stability experience and shadow wall
experience yeah so draw jelly we have
five touch screens so five users can
draw their own jelly click and drag the
bell the feeding arms tentacles and when
they're satisfied with it set the jelly
free and will move up to the bankrupt
monitors in front of them will actually
animate and then they can also at the
end choose to send a email from
themselves this is the pulse adélie
interactive there'll be three stations
three pulsing plungers we call them and
the idea is it's in the rhythm and
movement section of the experience we
want to be able to get a sense for what
it feels like for a jelly to move so
push this plunger up and down and the
jelly will
it's been around and move around so our
bioluminescence interactive jelly wall
uses an infrared technology to see your
movements so there's a camera up in the
ceiling at a hard angle to the screen
and then there's infrared light near the
projector so your new Fred lights are
casting a shadow that the camera can see
so it knows where where you are in the
same verses where it isn't where there
is nobody so then you can interact with
the fidelity's with your with your
shadow so after leaving the jellies
experience we're hoping that our
visitors increase their fascination with
the species